first for for both of you here you get
this really unique opportunity where you
get to work with almost the entire
ensemble in a consistent environment so
it was kind of making making me wonder
if you could uh compare and contrast the
actors you get to do those interrogation
scenes with so is there any one actor
where i don't know your process is just
aligned and you were in sync the second
you sat down to do those scenes and then
is there another one you can name drop
who you know challenged you to adapt and
kept you on your toes the most the thing
about this show is and and you you have
to give our producers and our our cast
and director diana brigitte um so much
credit because she brought together such
a powerful group of young actors
you know troy and i are the old guys
like we've been around the block for a
while um but to see
you know
young actors who really care about the
work and young actors who really want to
bring
a strong point of view sometimes you're
right sometimes it does clash and
sometimes it's like oh yeah we're just
kind of we're kind of like we're
grooving right now um i think when you
clash with with a younger actor it's
it's typically because
your processes don't necessarily line up
or
they're just not as um they're not as
curious
about the
way
of getting a result and they're more
focused on just getting the result but
so many of these young actors they're
just incredibly
talented at coming in with a strong idea
and a strong take and being present and
if it doesn't align with us like that's
okay because there's a thing called
editing and you know if on the other
side of the camera like we're giving
them weird looks they're gonna where
they're gonna use a different take so
these kids are bringing it they're
bringing it and and some of them again
some we gel really well with and some of
them it's like dang what is wrong with
that kid yeah um
you know
when you have such a large cache like
this you have so many different
personalities
right and so you have to mesh you have
to it's it's it's
it's all going towards the show it's all
this it's it's the beginning to the end
right so you all have to kind of like
show up and do your work and
but there were a couple of guys um that
that this season that i was i was
humbled to appreciate because i saw
myself in these guys when i was their
age you know um none of them came in
with an attitude because i mean you're
coming into a a train that's already
successful there's always it's already
on a hundred so now you got to find your
your way
onto this platform
and you really have to kind of like step
up and shine because everybody on this
show is doing their work you know they
they're they're they're here to to put
on a good
a good show so there was no egos um that
was surprising because
i think i had a little ego in the
beginning when i when i was coming up
you know what i mean
but um everybody was willing to help one
another everybody was willing to step to
the side and say hey let's run these
lines and
and um they were asked they you know
some of them asked david and myself hey
how was that and
it's like hey do you do the work man
it's it's it's there you're here for a
reason you earned it so let's go and
play and let's go and shine
those were lovely answers but i'm not
letting either of you off the hook i
want you to name drop one actor who
threw you a curveball and surprised you
actually i'll put the spoiler warning up
at this portion of uh of the interview
so you could talk about it freely what's
one actor who just like really shocked
you in the room with something special
reed um
he plays um
so many uh scotty
scotty
um and
you know a lot of the a lot of the young
kids they don't have a lot of experience
when it comes to you know being on a
stage like this um but he really
surprised me to the point where
i had to step back
and
gave him a little twinkle here and there
like hey
good job just to reconfirm that
you know it's not easy being around the
the director the producer the writers
when you're on stage and when you have
that spotlight on you sometimes it can
get intimidating you know um not to say
that he was because
he's a beast within himself i mean he's
a musician he's a singer and everything
but when you come into a stage such as
this
you know you you kind of you're a little
more reserved right so
but once he got warmed up and everything
it was just like wow okay you really
really shine put it like this no one was
asked if that's what you're looking for
no one was an ass on set okay
you know it's it's hard to have such a
large cast like this and and no one
being ass you know what i mean we would
not be in that environment anyway
because we're much older than the kids
on the show so we had our own kind of
like you know uh um little kind of group
that we would initially hang out with
but just being around the kids everybody
was just open and having fun what do you
say dave
yeah i mean it's i i they're true
artists i mean they're you know i i
don't think i guess i can speak for
myself i wasn't really encouraged to
pursue the arts you know 30 years ago
and i think i think kids nowadays
they have access to so much like the kid
wants to learn how to play piano he can
pull up youtube if he wants to learn how
to play guitar you can join a group and
and getting a you know a guitar group
online like there's i think over half
the boys if not
more are musicians as well singers
guitar players drummers
um uh
in bands and i think you know when
you're dealing with artists they
approach it from a completely different
uh way because it's about creating
something artistic and it's about
creating something beautiful and they
obviously
they had the privilege of seeing how the
first season worked and seeing how you
know uh the story that we were trying to
tell and they come in and they have a
lot of information that they've
processed and they've
they've brought to the table um and so
yeah i think these kids are really
really talented and uh
and and i think that that people are
gonna be
really really uh um
i guess encouraged by what they what
they did bring in their performances
all right before they kick me out of
here i'll squeeze in one more for
for your characters in particular now
they've got like a lot of secretive
unspoken plans and intentions going on
so and you know like some i'm aware of
at this point i'm sure there's more on
the horizon but when you're playing
characters like that what kind of i
guess serves as you know the main anchor
for you where no matter what they're up
to no matter how their plans shift you
know that you know that is always at the
core and driving their decisions i think
it's information i think it's data i
think it's the research i think the
overall good is learning why teenagers
do the things they do and and what they
do if the the
the circumstances are
uh somewhat controlled um i think
especially nowadays with teenagers
there's just so many distractions and so
many um little dopamine fixes that they
get that they sometimes forget how to
live their lives uh troy and i both have
kids and and and we you know we see
this this generation and how many just
distractions there are but to put you
know a group of of of young men and
young women in a um
in an environment where there are no
distractions and they do have to deal
with real life
you learn a lot about
uh human beings and you learn a lot
about the teenager's perspective and you
also learn about lots about yourself
because you were once a team
so it's it's it's reminiscence of
when you came up in school and
boyfriends and girlfriends and all that
good stuff so
you know it's it it reminds you of who
you it reminds you of yesteryear as they
say so you'll enjoy it
how about for your character though
what's what's the anchor what's backing
up all of his decisions that he makes
along the way um his morality sort of um
conflict that he has within himself
um because he's dealt with a lot of
trauma
within his personal life that
kind of um um
helps his his decision-making on his job
um so emotionally conflicted and
necessarily wanting to see
a positive outcome to these to these
groups of
kids you know he has a kid of his own so
um um
he he he really wants to see justice and
we we're still in the mindset
of gretchen's plan and her vision and we
want to see that
um prevail
uh but over you know over
over the episodes we kind of see that
that's diminishing a little bit so the
the moral conflict that he's dealing
with he's struggling with um is going to
be pleasantly uh revealed
at the end
um of season two and um i i think that
it's going to be interesting to see the
journey that dean took to get to where
he
is going to get so yeah well i i liked
what i got from him this season but i'm
very curious to see where their paths go
in
that is a very different place for the
two of them to end all right
i must leave you thank you guys for your
time today and congrats on season two
thank you